[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants boers
nounours et fort élégant ce soir nicolas
et pimprenelle vont faire mon portrait à
tout à leur patron ont les cheveux
europe
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop gros pot
aux roses voilà décret de toutes les
couleurs des blanches défaire du joug
des bleus tu t'es rouge j'espère qu'il
sera sage qui posera pas trop bonsoir
les enfants
où vous avez déjà préparé tout votre
matériel de dessinateur
nous allons faire ton
assieds toi ne bouge pas là je suis posé
ton et la teneur du côté des neuf noms
de l'autre côté annonce non ce n'est pas
mon bon trois fils
la tête basse la peine
move pas la paix je souris la bleue et à
pedro sur l'ennemi tiens toi droit mais
tu te lèves peur c'est fatiguant de
rester assis sans bouger j'ai des
fourmis dans les pas droit non pas six
hommes au
[Musique]
les flammes
une oreille relève la tête le nom
de le gros coq à l'âne ou non avec
moi l'abattement ja rule
[Rires]
genou et nous avons fait pourquoi mon
portrait c'est vrai montel mois non
puisque tu t'es endormi tu veux
mais tu verras une prochaine fois bonne
nuit les petits
on a bien soin de volume on dresse un
portrait il te mange
mon niveau ronel fait bourrel nikaïa
[Musique]
alors nounours comment est ton portrait
pour ne pas vu patron je me suis endormi
en route mon bon nounours bonne nuit les
enfants allez vite vous coucher le fuck
de boer heures
[Musique]